so the Joker movie just came out and to
be honest I wasn't gonna see this movie
because I'm not watching that many
movies these days but because of the
insane press that it was getting because
of the fact that everybody was afraid of
the movie that everybody was speaking
ill especially in the mainstream media
about this movie I thought okay there's
something else going on here and I have
to see it to understand why this
particular movie is making people freak
out and so that's mostly what the movies
gonna be about I'm gonna go through the
Joker movie and I'm going to show you
why the reason people are so afraid of
the Joker movie has much less to do with
the story in terms of the violence or
the way that the Joker acts but it has
more to do that in the very structure of
the storytelling it breaks apart the
political narratives that have been
prevalent in America and it smashes the
Overton Window to smithereens
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so if you haven't seen this movie please
don't watch this video because it's
going to be so full of spoilers you
can't believe I'm not going to spare you
at all I'm going to go through all the
elements of the movie and I'm going to
show you how the decisions made by the
screen writer and the director are there
to break down the prevalent narrative
that we find in our culture and that is
why the movie is so dangerous to the
mainstream to the establishment to all
of this and it has much less to do with
the violence although it is a it is a
very violent movie and it is horrifying
but you know the movie it just came out
two weeks ago and so why is it that a
movie about a killer clown that kills
children does not bother people but
somehow this movie about a man who
becomes crazy and starts to kill people
why is it that this movie is bothersome
and it has to do with the manner in
which it breaks down the current
narrative so I'm going to go through the
movie and I'm going to this is not the
usual way I do things but because the
movie just came out no time for editing
no time for fancy splicing and of scenes
I'm just going to go through the
elements of the movie and break it down
to help you see why it is why it is
doing what it is doing so if you've seen
the movie you will know everything about
it so I will take that for granted as I
go ahead and explain things now the
first thing to notice of course is his
name his name is great his Arthur Fleck
and in that name you find two
interesting things brought together one
which is Arthur of course the King
Arthur and the other is the notion of
Affleck Fleck is something which is
thrown away it is a piece of dust a
piece of debris which is which is thrown
out which is kind of flex off and so
this notion of Affleck and Arthur is
very interesting because of course as
you have watched the movie just like
King Arthur his origin is ambiguous King
Arthur's origin is extremely ambiguous
because he is an illegitimate son of a
king and that is what is you're led to
believe in the story it is that the
Joker at first you'd like to believe
that he's the illegitimate son of Thomas
Wayne and then you find out that in fact
no that is a fiction is it it's an
insane fiction and so this but but the
Joker does in the end become this kind
of kingly figure but a a kingly figure
of the of the chaos you could say a king
of chaos something like that and so the
name Arthur Fleck already is a is a very
well chosen name for what the Joker is
and what the Joker becomes so the movie
begins with a garbage strike and this
accumulation of garbage in the city is
of course a just a very literal you guys
gonna catch me because I said the word
literal but a very direct image of how
everything is piling up in the city how
the chaos is growing in the city of
Gotham and you see the Joker spinning
the sign which says everything must go
and there you go that's the beginning of
the movie everything must go and that's
what this movie is about and because it
it's going to break down all the
narrative structures that we identify in
our culture right now and that is
uncomfortable for everybody and it's
uncomfortable even for those who think
that they are somehow edgy somehow that
they're the ones were holding the
revolutionary hand but this is this will
this movie has nothing just nothing to
to do with that it's gonna break
everything apart and so in a way the
Joker movie is the most punk-rock movie
that I've seen in a very long time
because it takes on everything and
smashes it so how does it do that
how does it break down the narratives
what it does is that it sets up certain
situations and the situations which it
sets up are the situations which you
would expect in the current political
climate in the current way that people
put facts together or put elements
together and then what it does is it
breaks that down it shatters it as it's
setting it up and so that is what is
making people so uncomfortable about
this move yep so I'm going to give you
some examples which are going to help
you understand why this movie is feels
so dangerous to people now the the very
first image that I can bring up for you
is that there is this character his
clown friend this bully and they show
him as a bully because he's making fun
of the short person the [ __ ] in the
movie and so they shown as this bully
and so this bully this big you know this
big huge white guy you know he's got
everything you need to make him look
like like that bully character he gives
Arthur flak a gun now that's what you
would expect of course because he fits
the typify image but then the Arthur
Fleck character takes this gun and he
uses it but he uses it to kill these
elite kind of Wall Street types as he
calls them that himself these three
young Wall Street types you know looking
like the Covington kids type of guys and
so already you have this problem you
have this smash which is that on the one
hand you want to certain political
narratives will want to say yes of
course here's this bully type character
giving him a gun being interested by in
guns but then the gun is used to kill
the elites in society and so and so and
so how how do you deal with that because
the the gun ownership in the political
narrative of the way
is is seen as you know the powerful who
have these these guns and it's a
powerful who are defending the use of
guns but now it's used in a kind of
revolutionary manner but even in that
scene again everything is broke it
breaks down because you see the Joker
sitting in the Train and you see these
three kind of young rich kids who are
bullying this young lady and so when
they come and they beat up on the Joker
they beat up on earth reflect you feel
sorry for him of course and you you can
that that story is typify these three
bullies kind of harassing a young lady
and so finally you think the Joker
defends himself and he shoots one of the
guys and so you and so there's this
there's this disturbing sense of
catharsis in the moment but then he not
only killed the guy but he goes out and
he hunts the third guy down and he
shoots him down in cold blood it's
already the the narrative of the
revolutionary narrative you would say he
is already broken down because the extra
step that he takes to go hunt him down
to shoot him down with a gun and this
gun is an evil thing in American in
let's a left-leaning American narrative
the the idea of killing elites is a
left-wing fantasy and so how did you
drive these things together in the
modern political landscape so that
breaks it down another way that the
story gets broken down is in the very
character of arthri Fleck himself
because on the one hand he is portrayed
as someone who is poor someone who is
suffering someone who has been abused he
has portrayed as a victim but in the
modern political landscape today we have
had all this talk about these dangerous
in cells and these kind of dangerous
lonely guys who are who are a social
threat so portraying him as a victim and
at the same time having him as being
this
this disturbing character who has become
the big boogeyman of the modern world
right now it's very interesting to see
you know the way that people view in
cells today in terms of the the media is
very similar to the way that some guy
some racist white guy in the 1930s would
have viewed african-americans who would
have thought oh those those black people
are gonna come and get us you know
they're dangerous and so we have this a
very similar narrative today where it's
like now all these oh there's an army of
in cells out there that is gonna come
and get us and so you know not that not
that that can't happen
just like violence you know any kind of
group that is marginalized that is
suffering that one that it can happen
that violence will erupt out of that
community but you know we we're not yet
going to have a not all in cells hashtag
maybe we should who knows but but we see
that in that element and so another
another way in which all the the
expectations are broken is that you have
this poor character Arthur Fleck and his
mother who's writing letters to Thomas
Wayne and so Thomas Wayne is represented
as this jerk and he's you know he's got
he looks exactly like you would expect
him to it kind of overweight you know
big guy you know with a tuxedo who talks
about people who are not succeeding he
talks about the poor and about the
marginalized in society as a bunch of
clowns and so you have the story of this
lady who would add in the in the past
poor lady would have had an affair with
Thomas Wayne
so Thomas Wayne would have shut her up
you know like an abusive man in the
Epstein style would have shut her up and
he couldn't she couldn't get anything
from him
so she was forced to raise this young
man alone and so aha it's like we have
it we've got our narrative this is this
is the narrative big mean rich man
Hughes's woman takes advantage of her
she has a child and now this child is
mentally ill and you know that's the
story that's the story but then the
story is broken because turns out that
she's delusional
that it isn't the case that in fact she
you know she adopted this child and
Thomas Wayne is not the Joker's father
and so Thomas Wayne remains a jerk you
know of the things that he said at the
beginning are still extremely annoying
and extremely disturbing but then he's
also not this he's not what the story
has brought him up to be and so the idea
that somehow are through Fleck would
want to wreak vengeance upon him doesn't
have any meaning anymore and so this
this narrative is broken as well so
constantly in the story that is what
we're seeing we're seeing expectations
brought up and then those expectations
being cut at the knees so that you
cannot hold on to the narrative that you
think the movie should have in order to
justify its existence and that is why so
many people have been angry and just
annoyed and and can't deal with the
movie itself and so the movie is in in
the story we kind of explore this notion
of not having an identity so arthur
fleck loses his identity as the movie is
is moving forward
he first discovers he thinks that you
know he has these fantasies about about
connecting with the talk-show host he
has then this dream of maybe being the
son of Thomas Wayne and all of these
identities that he has are broken down
and so he becomes in a way the same kind
of anonymous ident you know he's adopted
we don't know who his real parents are
his mother is abusing him and so he he
is without any identity he's the picture
of nihilism
the thing about nihilism is that
nihilism
is not on anybody's side and that is why
so many people are frustrated with it I
read a review on The Associated Press
which says I wish the movie thought was
as radical as it thinks it is and that's
hilarious because the movie is not about
radical in the political sense and what
he means by that of course is radical
like I would want it to be radical in
the way that I interpret reality I
interpret politics I saw a very similar
review of it on the Roger Ebert website
where they criticize the the producers
for not being courageous enough not
being brave enough you know for example
not making the Joker character into a
racist you think huh why did they say
that very fascinating because if you had
made him racist then it would have been
easy to classify him it would have been
easy to say oh he's that kind of
horrible evil person but no because he's
not a racist because he falls in love
with this african-american woman then
you just can't put him in a category and
that is what annoys everybody so much
and I understand it because that is the
clown that is the the trump card that is
the the the card that has no category
the one that can be anything that you
think it is and at the same time none of
them at all and that is why the movie
itself ends up being what the Joker is
smashing everything nothing everything
must go and that seems to be what the
the movie is really about and you know
this is me speculating but it seems like
in a way the the movie is also a comment
coming from the director the director
expressed just before the movie came out
that he decided to make more dramatic
movies and stop making comedies because
he who can make a comedy in this woke
culture and that that seems to be the
moment where the media really
turned on him really decided to start
attacking him and you see there's a
scene in the movie where the Joker is
sitting in the couch of the talk-show
host we have to understand the talk-show
host as this political gatekeeper
you know the Stephen Colbert of toxa
host and all those other political talk
shows which are out there who have
somehow
may decide what is funny and what isn't
and you see in the Joker he says he
talks about the establishment and he
says you decide what is funny and what
isn't and then he points to their
cruelty there are a few very very
powerful little there's so many little
tidbits in this movie that help you
understand what it is that is trying to
be portrayed and and how it really is
this movie which is trying to break down
all narratives and the narrative of
course is seen as that elite the ones
who are holding the story the ones who
are holding the politics Thomas Wayne
the the talk-show host there are those
are the ones who are holding the reins
and so there is a there's a scene where
they show on television you see him in
his apartment and it's in the background
and you see this kind of gaudy scene of
you know african-american workers were
kind of singing and it's and it's this
kind of really bad you know image of
these kind of black workers that are
singing and and it every the whole
cliche of the the kind of poor black man
who sings jazz and you know the whole
cliche of the shoe-shining
black person all of that is is there and
it's kind of it's kind of disturbing to
see that on the television and you think
oh man what is going on and so so then
you think aha maybe this movie there's
so many scenes like that maybe this
movie really is racist maybe that's what
it is and then there's another scene
where you where the Joker walks into a
movie theater and all these these people
all these rich elites in tuxedos are
sitting there and watching Charlie
Chaplin as the hobo and all of them are
laughing at this homeless man who is
spinning on his skates and you realize
that you realized this how how much this
is not so much how it is really is this
breakdown of everything
it really is everything must go but the
ultimate thing that I think is making
people crazy is how it crosses the
different narratives together and gives
us something which seems impossible but
that people just can't stand to watch
which is that Joker is the you know is
this bitter insel character but then he
ends up becoming the figurehead for a
type of Occupy Wall Street movement
where everybody's wearing a mask it's a
clown mask instead of a Guy Fawkes mask
but you can see that it's all related to
the same thing there are places in there
little scenes of the movie where for
example people hold up signs and it says
Wayne fascist and they have resist signs
and so here is this here is the bad guy
of here's the new bad guy of
contemporary culture this clown in cell
you know lonely guy who lives with his
mother and he is the cause he is the
inspiration for a movement which is an
Occupy movement of resistance and
anti-fascist movement and so it's like
smash the two narrative together and no
wonder people cannot stand it now mind
you the movie is extremely disturbing
the need to watch this character become
crazy to watch him kill his mother to
watch him you know become this brutal
character is extremely unsettling but in
terms of the actual violence it is no
less unsettling than any
other movie that has that type of story
in it you know that the movie it just
came out two weeks ago there are all
these horror movies which usually come
out in the month of October we are in
the month of October we know this is the
month for horror movies but somehow this
movie is the one that is freaking people
out and and and that's what it is it
really is
that's what's so unsettling about the
movie is that everything let's go the
whole thing is the entire narrative of
the narratives are thrown up in the air
smash together and and and and broken
down and very few people can handle that
and I understand why they can't handle
it but what it can help us see if we are
attentive it can help us understand what
kind of narratives we are attached to
what are the stories that we think are
the stories which are unfolding before
us what what is holy to us and that's
what a clown does a clown is always
pointing and taking apart the things
that you care about the clown is always
turning things upside down he's always
making fun of the things that we hold
dear that is the role of a clown and
just because just because some people
think that they're right and that their
narrative is the only narrative doesn't
mean that there won't be a clown there
to poke at it so that's my review of the
Joker guys if it is disturbing and it is
very violent so I'm not necessarily
recommending that you go see it but for
sure I think that it's playing a strange
role in our culture and you know the
Joker in the movie at some point tells
his psychologist that the name of his
clown act is carnival and so it's
October guys it's Halloween it's time
for Carnival everything's going to be
thrown up in the air
and this month I will be putting out
some videos on Halloween explicitly I'll
be putting out some videos on specific
monsters you know I'm trying to get all
of it together I put out a Twitter poll
to see which monsters you guys want to
hear about and they were almost all very
equal so let's see which ones I'm going
to choose I might try to do all of them
and I'll keep one of the monster videos
for the patron only video so the guys
thanks for your support I hope you
enjoyed this this format it's the first
time that I do this kind of immediate
interpretation format and I will see you
guys soon if you enjoy the symbolic
world content there's a lot of things
you can do to help us out you're not
subscribe please do go ahead and share
this to all your friends if you can get
involved in the discussion we have a
Facebook group in which people can talk
about these subjects I will put all
those links in the description and also
if you can please support us financially
by going to my website
www.jfn.co.jp/toho